on this episode stick with me here we go
to the gym with me
[Music]
ah
this is
ask Gary B this is so ridiculous this
this is so ridiculous
ready yeah everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 163 of
the askgaryvee show it's a little bit of
a ridiculous show I'm even regretting it
as we're like doing this right now
we'll try to get through this um yes so
I had to get my workout in I just landed
from LA and I really wanted to do the
show today I was like in a good good
mood for it and I was on Wi-Fi in
DeMaio's like you're not going to fit it
in and I'm like well just send them to
the gym some mics here we're gonna
answer some questions in the air so
let's uh show India these here at the
gym it's so ridiculous uh and Dee rocks
gonna hate this episode isn't I mean I
literally look like I'm in a dungeon
somewhere trapped so uh India let's get
into the show just brush my teeth it's
disgusting yeah yeah Chad asks so the
square IPO what are your thoughts on the
future of global credit services yeah I
think that um this is I need there's
there's a vine out there by the way of
me like on the toilet I don't know if
people know this but um this is starting
to feel like a little bit this was
starting to feel like a really bad idea
um I think that uh I think the wallet
will be eliminated and that we will all
pay with our mobile devices maybe with
our fingerprints but the the wallet is
antiquated it's like a magazine it's
like carving in in the caves and I think
over the next ten years technology will
be be really in a place where we can go
full throttle on electronic payments
obviously there's the blockchain and all
that world with Bitcoin there's
also the fact of my historic behavior
four years ago maybe five I invested in
venmo maybe six so I've been on this
kick for a while I'm a big believer and
I think with Apple pay you're seeing
more behavior around this and I'm
extremely bullish so if you're playing
in a space that is like like you make
portraits for wallets or you make
wallets that's something to be concerned
about over the next decade and even and
on the flip side if you can support an
ecosystem where people don't carry
wallets so like what's the ChaCha
that needs to be made in a world where
your phone is really your payment thing
so like what's the official beats by dre
license carrier with the phone thirty
six months from now that like is the hot
ship that everybody's got on the gram or
whatever anybody's paying attention to
in thirty six months that's where I'd be
using this wave as this entrepreneurial
venture opportunity
uh-huh yeah we got it we got a respect
Mike in this scenario where the wall all
right oh just lay on it yeah
this way good good one on the ground
yeah oh this yeah yeah all right go
ahead all right
Ruba Ruffa ass I have a startup idea to
improve women's underwear I'm scratching
my own itch but no nobody in the
business advice so India you and I
worked on this one today uh we saw this
tweet I sent it to you you went to go
reach out to her she deleted it what did
she say did she like I love it um Mike
this star to get good look at that yeah
the Rasik um one more we'll just bang
this out um Ruba I think that uh I think
that uh that this answer is actually the
answer to your question which is you
don't know me everybody you don't know
me you don't know me and you tweet it at
me and Here I am responding to you and
giving you feedback in the same way that
you can go and map all 700 executives in
the industry and hit them up on Twitter
and say hello I'd like to talk to you
about my business idea and literally
three of them will say yes two of them
will cancel on you and one out of the
700 people and if you think about three
to five minutes per engagement three
minutes to write the engagement maybe
and kind of check it and then maybe four
to ten hours of research of who those
700 executives are that you need for
marketing or production or the reaches
or the retail world right
like as you try to convince them I just
so this is the most this is way up there
with ridiculous things that I've done
I'm so sorry to the vaynernation I
thought I don't know what what I decided
I don't know how this happened anyway I
think that um um I like take my work out
serious too um so I think you have to go
and reach out to and so like I'm telling
you that you're going to get to one
person maybe two by spending 80 90 hours
of time which scares way too many of you
off the problem is what's the
alternative the problem is what is the
alternative when you're at the bottom
and you've got nothing you've got a
scrap it's like me and Mike when we
first now I can use this genomic estar
using this Jim when we first started
here 16 months ago Mike told me to do
this this and I couldn't do it I can do
it that's hell at the bottom physically
I was and then we just systematically
did things that whole thing when I was
like this is good
literally 60 days ago I couldn't do crap
with that because we haven't like worked
on that flexibility so anyway what you
have to do is you have to find the 700
people and you have to go and get them
and I would use Twitter
LinkedIn is a place you can use as well
the problem is so many people spam on
LinkedIn you get so much more upside on
Twitter especially if you don't just
like like spam them with the first move
you know jab jab and right hugging um
I'm saved wrong anyway uh so that's it
put in the work put in the work
hold on one second in you I got a prime
take this as the priority just warming
up uncles pearls yep crap we're doing
armed I like the thing I'm weakened this
is where I get exposed for the thing I'm
weakest added curl 40s that's not like
any fitness people that watch will be
like curling forties is really
impressive yeah cool cuz I could let me
show you what I started with I was like
I'm like this is never gonna happen that
but we started but by the way this was
real and it was like curling yeah
I buy subsidize my biceps have been the
hard for me my tries have been good
Trezeguet
you like just I well okay go ahead
Sean ass I was asked to fill out a
self-evaluation but I think these are
just a waste of time and don't help that
much what do you think I think it
depends on who's on the receiving end of
the self evaluation there are things
that I've done in my career where I've
asked employees to do things and never
then read it and that was obviously a
waste of time
right and like that's not fun for me
admit but like things that I learned as
a kid at Wine Library the truth is even
as vaynermedia there's been things that
I've done a lot of my employees now now
let's do it for on a call for two
minutes instead of emailing me because
it's not how I roll if somebody's on the
other end listening to that feedback and
actually does something with that
feedback the self evaluation is
tremendous I think you're barking up the
right tree though is I don't think
that's happening in 99 percent of
organizations mainly because the intent
isn't there to give a crap enough about
the employee and so my cynical point of
view of how businesses are treating
their employees leads me to you're
probably right now if you're there
because you believe I'd like to think
that India feels good about doing it at
vaynermedia with me on my team so then
it's valuable but I think I think it
comes down to more about how much you
believe in the organization more so than
the tack
dick that is deployed in a
self-evaluation I also think people are
full crap and self valuations like
you're always going to give yourself if
it's 50/50 if you're like am I'm good or
great great am i lazy or just solid I'm
solid
so like everybody's always leaning to
their best benefit it's human nature no
I think that's a good point I do think
some people are stunningly hard on
themselves but yes I think you know
first of all it's a good opportunity I
never think anything is 100% the hell is
100% nothing but yes I do think the far
majority and 94% which allows me to say
everybody what do you want done in
push-ups
I can do these hang these out all right
go ahead all right get down here Stefan
I want you to work with me Vincent asks
if you were going to start a restaurant
in the world we live in now how would
you go about it
well I think maple start up by invested
in Mike I'm not counting is uh is doing
it which is it's a restaurant that in
New York City that doesn't have a place
to actually go in so it realizes that by
percentage you play the maths especially
in New York City and I was hoping in New
York your economics are so much better
being a delivery company than actually
having the overhead of the restaurant is
something I think about a lot with Wine
Library which is a bricks and clicks
organization we have a lot of overhead
to run the store versus the dot-com and
it's how much energy you want to put
against it so I'd probably launch a
restaurant
that was very unique in the way that it
served patrons locally in a physical
restaurant environment maybe open on
Saturdays only and then the rest was
delivery something clever something that
gave it pizzazz based on what I was open
and then and then the delivery would be
the backbone and the infrastructure in a
New York environment somewhere else I
probably go for I'd find an amazing chef
and go for like pork would have porridge
so I brought up the other day I try to
win on something that other people
aren't doing a bunch of like obviously
tacos and premium burgers I still don't
think there's a hotdog winner you know
feels like there's somebody going to win
the Shake Shack hot
game so Chris ass is it more effective
to market your humble self or a
caricature of yourself in today's
service-based tech industry Chris the
best thing to do this is a good time to
answer this question the best way to do
anything is to be the truth so sometimes
I'm humble and sometimes I'm egotistical
and sometimes I'm ridiculous and this
would be one of those times I think your
honest self is always the right answer
if you're trying to play to what the
market likes right now you're going to
always have to change right
right now entrepreneurship is cool by
the way when the tech bubble bursts when
God forbidden and I haven't been able to
a semi love to a lot of my business
associates that live in the Paris Area I
obviously grew up in the wine business
know a lot of people in that town and so
god forbid when that hat what not if
when that happens in the US and the
market pops entrepreneurship is not
going to be hot practical paying your
bills is going to get hot we've had a
great 10-year run here that everybody's
kind of living in right now and all you
youngsters haven't really tasted the
alternative given tasted the stock
market splitting in half jobs not being
available you're not getting recruited
by everybody your homies will school
saying come start a business with me
practicality is really on the horizon I
see it oh there you are practicality
it's coming and when it comes it's going
to be an interesting market change this
show hopefully I'm doing it when it
happens well hopefully I'm not so
Coakley doesn't happen for a while but
um I think you have to be you because I
was entrepreneur when it wasn't sexy I'm
entrepreneur now I promise you and I'll
play this clip 22 years from now I will
be entrepreneur when it's not sexy again
awesome we're getting into 40th
sure okay where's diesel okay cool I'm
excited
she's us and hammers under him like all
right question of the day what's going
on with your workout regimen were you in
your process with your thing India where
do you n take you keep asking questions
Mike will keep making me lift weights
see you guys later thanks for watching D
rock eat it bad lighting that's it yeah
I did one extra C
[Music]